[Music]
a very Merry Christmas to you
welcome back I'm joined by John Yin
Yousef from propane fitness harbour
hello as you can see we are
festively add Aunt Mary crumble for that
time of the year and for the listeners
at home at home we have a special
present for you as well don't we
Jonathan this specialist of presents if
on the count of three you say the word
lights on one very clue three lights
look at that so wonderful for the people
who are not watching on YouTube
Johnny is lit up very spangly Christmas
jumper which is available from next I
think discount codes John Johnny Johnny
175 for 25% off yeah but it's lovely man
can it stop man my epilepsy is gonna
kick it maybe if we see lights again on
the count of three one two three lights
still on
right anyway so we are going to do a
year in review we're gonna talk about
the best life hacks that we've come up
with this year what habits we have set
which we think have worked talk about
some massive fails of which there will
be numerous examples and then maybe
discuss some plans going into 2019 so by
the end of this episode you may have got
some inspiration for some habits that
you can instantiate as we move forward
into the new year and if not you will be
able to laugh at some of our failures
from the last one also you will notice
that our our friend Robin is perched
upon the top of the mic called Martin
Martin Martin Martin
he's South African it's Robin okay so
phone a long way
I don't even start me we start me okay
Scott it's like hot potato
catch this um you should've got a big
bowl of hot potatoes you got the low
this um Yussef hmm biggest fail it is
Christmas it is Christmas is the time of
giving I want you to give the listeners
at home
a massive use of fail big big fail from
this year yeah I I just failed into this
year to be honest so I started this year
having just come out of hospital enjoy
us it was I got the gitis so I had had
three or four infections just
back-to-back ended up in hospital for
eight or nine days and then came out ten
day retreats instantly and then came out
of the retreat into the New Year at 67
kilos which is ten kilos below my my
baseline so I started on a low and
actually managed to build up this year
over that time if you've followed
protein for a while you'd have seen that
I've turned this into a kind of
journalistic piece called project swirl
where I invited anyone who's had a bit
of a rough time over the the previous
few months to to join me in coming back
to baseline swell them back to scold him
Rios Walden yeah and it was great
actually it's it's really good to know
that you don't you can't really undo
years of training even if you do have
like a bit of a shock real catastrophic
period yeah that's quite nice
I mean you entered the ER quite badly I
entered the very very badly because I
contracted the norovirus as I was in
Manchester on New Year's Eve I remember
the 2017 into 2018 didn't I just so yeah
I I found myself in Manchester running
one of our events down there
suffering the beginning of vomiting and
diarrhea without it hadn't onset yet
because it's like um what's it called
breaking the seal like I hadn't broken
the seal yet so still I felt
uncomfortable it needed to come out but
I was left at three in the morning in
Manchester with the awkward decision of
like what do I do now it's 3:00 in the
morning I not gonna be able find a hotel
it's 3:00 a.m. in Manchester on New
Year's Eve definitely not going to be in
any hotels I can ask to stay with a
friend but if asked to stay with a
friend I'm gonna have to ask to have
their toilet for the evening and just
destroy it or I can try and drive home
remembering that I lived three hours
away from Manchester so I chose that
option the quickest ever journey from
you castle from Manchester to Newcastle
I've had burst through the door straight
into my bathroom and then lifted myself
off my feet with the pressure
of nausea decay but unlike the urgency
where it's like oh god it's gonna cause
something yeah it's gonna happen I uh
sighing it's good thanks grayfia you
just like games coming out if he does
love things
find me someone who doesn't fair enough
if you don't like things coming out of
you please comment below all stuff going
out you feel it meant just feel pretty
good some stuff going into you but not
all stuff some things going in yeah I
think there's more or as a lion share of
things because remember things to come
out of you like it's not to gonna go you
already have control over that selection
of things yeah yeah nicely put anything
into you yeah well if you got stealth
penetrated that's gonna be the trailer
for them it always is you don't wish
stealth porked every time Oh actually
yeah so can you explain how you navigate
through the Christmas food being a
Muslim ik so last year it was fine
because I was in a monastery where it
was purely vegetarian so you could just
go free
what about usually do you usually to be
honest I you know stealth porking
happens with things like pizza where
there's a pepperoni under the the cheese
or you have a ravioli Italian food
basically Italians are really noisy and
stealthy Christmas food like you can the
pork is obvious it's like sausages
wrapped in bacon mars-like I mean that's
Haram a smoked pork center [ __ ]
bosses so you stay away from that but
turkey cranberries it supposes that the
booze isn't it is a christmas-themed
sandwich recently that had chestnut in
vogue but not enough apparently
oh sure they learn this as I was
frantically googling while you're eating
is I'd eaten it down the hatch it's gone
and you've seen how quickly are you
sound can you tell us about the sandwich
at the wedding so that was that was just
a fall that was leading into this year
yeah yep so I ate a I've got a wedding
I've done a lot of weddings this year
she's been the year of the wedding you
know really I've I ate a sandwich
waiting a week
yeah you'd learn a lot though so there
was a pudding that was like an apple
strudel that was homemade that was like
looking they're gonna mmm not sure was
assured by everybody there that it was
not free it was then like a plate of
sandwiches so I got their strudel cup of
sandwiches
sit down I'm speaking to my girlfriend's
gran essentially you think the strudel
would be the high-risk thing that's
precisely my so I was like oh man I'm
like God and I was like I'm thinking
I'll look at that later and my
girlfriend's gram has a this thing that
every time she sees me the first thing
she does is asks what I've got my pen
with me first question I'm like because
she's very she has this fear I just get
very granny so I was speaking to her
right sandwich one down average sandwich
two down average again I'm good what
were the sandwiches because they were
very PG so this one was like I think
it's or all of them had the cross cut
off very wedding-y a very wedding
that's crush cut off like different
types of bread like cheese and pickle
cucumber chicken mayo like all that sort
of stuff so I just eaten the cucumber
one and bike mouth just goes mental like
pins in the instant pins and needles in
your mouth incident like lips pins and
needles so so this is actually funny
enough why I said this about the sick
thing because the first thing I do is
I'm like sucks at speaking to my
girlfriends and thinking I can't say
anything to her because she'll lizard
don't mind there's a wedding going on so
like I don't want it for it all this and
it's ironic I haven't actually got hire
people but I'm also going into
anaphylaxis because it might be other
factors might not be if it is they'll be
hunting pretty quickly so I need to pop
off so I went that I was like right no
problem
this time before just make myself sick
hadn't eaten anything all day up until
that's was the first food I've eaten and
it's all solid so like fingers on a buck
you throat try makes our seconds nothing
happens so you you give yourself of real
going-over then with your fingers oh god
what I'm thinking like options are I for
death like go gonna make my suppose
through this that was off sick
this is what it's like to be a young
Geordie the first night isn't it
this is how it's like to be an extra on
Geordie Shore exactly that I'm at
exactly how I felt
I remember seeing a clip from on Casino
Royale when Daniel Craig salt salt and
water but I'm in the toilet of it of a
castle where do you find salt nowhere
yeah apart from back in the room so I
thought so I went back into the room
whenever my girlfriend and one I'm
having a no reaction and she it was
weird kid I expected like it
- she's when the problems could get the
EpiPen and that was more worrying than
what was happening to me because if
she'd been panicked I'd be like it's
okay everything's normal but she was
like action stations yeah well [ __ ] and
that was the first time as I oh my god
oh my mother died
Yeah right what like I'm not lying would
all the constant fear I had in the
monastery in the meditation you were
adamant that you were going to pass away
it wasn't it and then when you're not
reassured that your mama died an
accident as well it wasn't that I was
gonna die it was that like my phone's
away I've got no contact with the
outside world
my mum's died Johnny's had anaphylaxis
girlfriend's broken up with me and I'm
gonna lose my leg because I that's in
the leg car yeah I'm gonna have to get
the brakes put on the car I'm gonna come
up John you'll have eaten an M&M and so
yeah so didn't die I just had a very
it's like an Alton Towers ride for four
hours the film I watched I watched the
Steve Jobs film but anyone says to me
come out it's awful to be honest like
what is that what are the effects of
anaphylaxis is it I didn't go into
anaphylactic shock so but you see what
was it that you say you rode just below
the anaphylactic like so rats so I've
had I've had a few minor not reactions
before and they were very tame like PG
12a at most
yeah this was 18 like this was already
feeling as well instant like as well
very much so it was in the cucumber
sandwich so it's cucumber and pesto the
most PG has not made from pine nuts
because she or something else but not
good like did not sit well with we were
saying the other day so it was three
doctors described
how would they get your birthday wasn't
it worth a in a Lebanese restaurant and
I said to this there's nuts on the menu
and I asked the lady is there nuts in
this you saying there's no nuts in the
kitchen right I'm allergic to oysters
sauce and I went to this Korean sandwich
place and I was like is there any
oysters source used in the chicken
sandwich and the guy was like oh no
don't worry it's totally vegan and
you're like that's just discredited
anything you can possibly say mate
more than anything I'm not gonna look
gonna get anything from you excuse me I
have a question I have a question so we
were saying like how if you didn't have
an EpiPen how would you keep someone
stable when the great anaphylaxis
without that we're thinking well I don't
know because it's like David had a biro
in his pocket news I'm gonna give you a
trichotomy with this yeah okay man like
one of the guys Julia to me was gonna
turn him upside down without without as
he taking Artyom Chaika upside down
shake and scream for adrenaline yeah
just try and take someone as much as I
would love to see anyone try and turn
100 yeah hundred kilo times that I think
of that of the selection people I know
that group of people there that night
let me tell you let me tell you what I'm
feelin genic yeah I tell you what would
have been a fairly okay way to do it
stack chairs on top of tables move the
tables apart sumo squat you from the
sumo deadlift you from the floor and
just standing there yeah just stay on
top yeah yeah well that is the way to
the only risk is with a sumo deadlift
that for so good now I've talked to
people on every side pushing their
people on either side and then you just
have a rotation of people hailing you
and Max ideally you'd have some kind of
grateful straps with you you need to
have a screamer on the bottom holding
your hair
[Music]
stay outside this rap I'd use you as
shoelaces is like straps going shivering
with Jason Statham in where he gets
poisoned and yes keep his adrenaline
yeah crank crank yeah and then there's
crank to where he had to use electricity
yeah so we should really like tricks his
hand in a toaster but it goes crazy [ __ ]
yeah that's I mean that's yeah okay so
moving on let's go on to a good habit or
one of your favorite habits or one of
your favorite routines that you've
managed to adds to your life this year
right so I think habits has been
journaling I got enough on my laptop
called day one
absolutely brilliant I know you too when
did it properly you got the six minute
die if they want I've kept a they want
to know what they want from I use it I
use day one okay I used a one for very
very specific things obviously you can
take photos in it and it's password
protected and so it's got a lot of like
significant moment okay me too so I
don't use it as a diary it just kind of
insights that come up and I'm sure six
minute diary would formalizing tasks
keep it probing questions but this is
more just like things that come up that
are important to note down bash them art
then you have a chronological
chronological order of it all so do you
so I kept it I kept two journals one in
day one and one in Evernote and I did
them pretty conservative pretty kinky a
and I remember just getting to the point
where I was like without sitting in
without creating a separate habit which
is going back and reviewing this stuff
I'm not sure what I'm getting out of it
so what do you get out of it why do I
have a process for that now cuz I
realized that a lot of my the last 10
years it's probably since before I got
Evernote I would just mindlessly
accumulate summaries of books that I've
been reading and just pile stuff in so
now Evernote copy the link paste it into
pocket read the audio on pocket would
listen to the audio on pocket while I'm
driving or read the audio at certain
increments and you can set timed
reminders with Evernote so that you can
look at a book that you've read a while
ago and so you feel stuff you're
basically using the Anki period izing
take you back through I know there was
that long article that George sent it
it's like really taking on key to this
full lives room and you know putting
your whole life into it but I think
that's quite a laborious process
Johnny is and I'm always inspired by
your ability to implement just so like
[Music]
the lights are going again to just you
read a book you take some lesson from it
and you implement a straightaway of just
just-in-time learning rather than just
in case I do
that's a ferret ISM yes yes I think the
ages now it's never made sense to me
to make notes on a book just because
like I think people think that once
they've taken notes is I've done that no
yeah I've got that in case I need it
it's so easy that don't you see it is
trying it away and there's so many
beautiful look like notes that you think
that is so valuable and all I did is
wrote it once and you look back on the
notes and it means last year like the
weight that that sentence carried when
you were reading it was such an insight
but if you can't remember it at all it's
better it's having the note better than
nothing yeah I mean I think as long as
it's in your own words seasoning the
review process is just as important as
the either so if it's sometimes to be
applied apply it if it's just something
that's important I think taking a
concept and writing it in your own words
in a way that then expecting like it's
some point five millimeter technique
right hmm well I mean I've done it sound
like a copycat but for me journaling
this year has also been a a huge change
so I got the 6-minute diary at the very
beginning of the why you take me but I'm
gonna have to take off one item of
clothing and you can't take off your
trousers sir I've got leggings on but I
said I can't be taken off my Christmas
jumper what something so it's gonna this
actually I promise this wasn't planned
right ah you look like your frog
you've got full leggings on this is
gonna work the sound of you taking your
trousers off it's gonna be
option by the why I get your package is
gonna be fully frontal now isn't it I
realized that so I think I'll just do
that while wearing like why are you
wearing leggings my boiler broke last
night so I've been I've been wearing all
the clothes that I have I can't believe
you've just done that uh I think it's
okay there's no package visit Jesus
Christ
is it still Christmassy reading from
Brent I'm gonna try and continue as if
nothing's occurred so are the list of
things that I would have could have
expected
might have happened that's not one of
them well I really like is that anyone
who skipped forward yeah
when did he take his trousers off yeah
and so yeah journaling for me has been
massive 6-minute diary is a real
game-changer I've instantiated a daily
habit for something that I never thought
I would do shout out to the guys that
make it because like I'm I'm not easy an
easy person to change with regards to
that but that's I guess that's going
over old ground we've spoken about that
before hmm I think my best development
from this year has been learning the
sacredness of a morning routine I've
always had one but never really treated
it very sacred and I thought the best
word I can come up with is what are you
dispensable just yeah very transit tree
like if it gets done it it's a bonus if
it doesn't get done it doesn't matter
and now I I almost look forward to going
to sleep because the start of my day
includes a lot of [ __ ] that I love to do
that's really nice I start my day with a
bunch of [ __ ] that's awesome so I'll get
up I will go and stand outside whether
it's raining whether it's whatever I'll
stand outside for a minute couple of
minutes and just take in the air coffee
breakfast sit down journal meditate we
have for breakfast always the same so it
is two sachets of quakers instant oats
golden syrup flavor then blueberries
combination of mixed nuts and yogurt
covered raisins and stuff and a
- smoothie innocent smoothies sometimes
I get greens drink water coffee sit down
no bro
not very good Lord makes me feel
comfortable morning
I'm muscular that's it - turgid yeah and
there's too much synthesis go printed
stop never feel even through the
Christmas jumper yeah it's just right on
the brink isn't it ready they're great
at this I was gonna say for a second / -
overfilled public pools oh and then yeah
I do lots of stuff that I like a journal
I meditate I read I've now got timer
whereas that way my reading for 20 or 25
minutes and I've very slowly managed to
cultivate a reading habit through doing
that then a rum wad now I'm adding on to
that as I'm contributing more articles
for Muslim Fitness Muscle & Fitness the
new one will be out in February so make
sure you check that out which is about
meditation itself and I'm sitting down
and cracking out like 500 500 words on a
morning then I get up and I go to the
gym I'm like well there's a microphone
and I haven't looked at my phone the
whole time I may be popped inside timer
on but I don't get I don't get sucked in
and I'm just like yeah by the time that
I got at the gym the day is about to
begin and yeah I've done so much [ __ ]
already and I'm just like if it makes
obviously makes waking up every day a
pleasure pleasure genuine pleasure what
about you Johnny I know that you like to
develop habits and read a lot mm-hmm
self-development yeah so I was on a
plane go into a wedding clothes you were
and I read a Darren Brown's book called
happy and I remember it's just like a
five hour flight to Cyprus I remember I
got on the plane and I had like he still
kind of do but like everything was
90-day goals with outcomes and I was I
really believe because of a lot of
people I follow believe this that like
targets and goals and things to tick off
were like the way to manage all hours of
your life
and Darren just system
ethically rubbish that belief for five
hours don t time speed that's a lot of
Darren and like I got off the plane I
was just like listen to it too
continuously oh it's a long but new you
say that you've got on you got on the
plane in like as one person and got all
that with your world delivery
well so like how often do you have five
hours to sit just listen to someone and
like it's like apart do you think that
they're around just like a magician he
is an incredibly well well-read
insightful very intelligent man he's
also a lawyer you know busy he's a
lawyer huge yeah but anyway so like
minutes and it very any like you're
taking lots of schools of thought
synthesizing into just this like goal
setting and in the way that essentially
I was doing at the time is completely
and utterly pointless was like great
okay so then that sort of started to
shift my beliefs recently read James
clears atomic habits which kind of put a
like a bottle cap on that thought
process of that you know actually you
know my version Mario Mariotti today and
what it will be like this time next year
in two years time all of us just like
something I'm experiencing on that point
in time so the process is the most
important thing and so since then I've
been more foremost removed the focus on
hitting a certain thing focus more on
like just installing something into my
life I've heard you use the term it's a
process goal not an outcome goal a lot
more in the last six months all over it
I think so that and a simplifying stuff
a lot yeah I think because when you
start looking at it as so like a lot of
the literature is this is 66 days for a
bit like that's thrown around all the
time so you think like okay I've gotta
do something for 66 days you immediately
view it differently to like I just wanna
hit this goal that would be nice and
then you think well I'm making a real
commitment here like I want to be
spending the next two months more doing
this thing how can I increase the
likelihood of that happening so that
then frames how you set the whole
process what you're saying about the
morning routine like little tiny little
changes have a bigger
so I remember you saying about leaving
your phone over to the side of the room
like that's a tiny tiny thing but if
completely changes how number one number
one difference it's made
so just I'm gonna step that up this here
actually so I'm going to this is taken
from Joe roll yourself to this right
that's me no because that would be that
would remove it stays in bed and I go
over the other side of the room right
Joe Rogan hasn't no phone's room in his
house I think he has a in his house yeah
so you walk through the door this is
little he's got like a 10 year old 11
year old daughter right so all of her
friends around and they will want a
snapchat and Facebook and Instagram and
and put bunnies on each other and stuff
like that and they all have to have the
funds they leave them at the front of
the door so they're all like the garage
no one wants to go around to like a
little Rogen's house because it's a
great money-making scheme you just have
a box at the front of the door tell
everyone that once they go in the house
you go up at Mon eBay you can only do
that once come well per friend you
needed constant supply friends and also
a way of buying back the lost social
equity so telling gain friends faster
than you can sell phones that's the
question
well if you know the answer please tell
us
yeah see it's a process goal and
simplifying my personal development just
like so I've been using Hawaii as a
process called better than a outcome
goal so in the endurance book which I
highly recommend reading called happy he
talked about this the idea of like the
experienced itself and the remembered
self and it's something that a lot of
people talk about but this in other
words you reaching a goal is always ever
just a point in time so if you CH even
outcome goal like that's just gonna
happen on a day at some point in the
future you'll experience that I don't
even like yeah exactly so like your
reality might have changed but it
probably your reality like your day to
day Monday to Friday or Monday to Sunday
is gonna be exactly the same you've just
done something and so that's not really
how we experience happiness
contentment we experience happiness and
contentment by you know on a daily basis
the fidelity is much higher yeah so like
having a really lovely morning every
morning yeah that's a big change in your
life having a really lovely evening is a
big change in your life doing one thing
in 90 days sign doesn't have a big
change in your life and obviously the
outcome requires a process but when you
look at it as actually in that case the
process is all the matters the outcome
is about takes care of yourself
yeah so that's awesome coming off the
Lighting's again please only Christmas
Jeff cause I'm missing him no lights oh
it's only buddy home may or may not be
included in the recording but I honestly
convinced you so for a couple of minutes
that this was a voice-activated jumper
fully and he that's why we have to
explain to you as well so that we felt
less silly so we've outsourced our
silliness another fail from this year
please we've gone another fail I had a I
had a win here's gonna win no okay no I
don't want to win or 30s with a win
don't have to check it's a it's in the
shape of a spoon spoon oh yeah okay this
is Chris really wanted me to tell this
story because it's hilarious so I've
been cold turkey coffee for a lot of
time for years actually because I
developed a real basically I can't have
a healthy relationship with coffee I can
only have an extreme high or extreme low
one so I was like right I'm just gonna
burn coffee it's all caffeine then
coffee there right yeah you know if you
don't like like I would have never heard
you say like I love coffee
I love it like okay it's not I'd say
it's a delivery mechanism for coffee
okay yeah that's true which I would
perfectly I would take IV if I could
just get access to
constituted caffeine so see I can't have
a healthy relationship with it that's
very much like what alcoholic says so
I've been cold turkey
I started reintroducing it tentatively
this year and found that yeah you get
absolutely when you reintroduce it's you
so sensitive to it that a single coffee
will send your heart rate up it'll send
you meet you so feeling like you're
soaked
directive whether you actually are
different story but what I found was
actually you're taking borrowed
wakefulness you're taking wakefulness
forward and front-loading it and then
later on in the day he started feel
tired and I actually never used to fall
asleep during the day as soon as I
started drinking coffee within a few
days I was falling asleep during the day
quite consistently in the afternoon and
I think it's because I was so sensitive
to it that the effect was lasting over
into the evening reducing my sleep
quality causing that tiredness to roll
on forward and to be tired during the
day one day this sounds so stupid but I
had slightly two heaped a spoon of
coffee they're not expecting we just
let's just repeat that I had a heat
spoon of coffee that as opposed to as
opposed to a little flat one it must
have been a tablespoon I don't know how
to dose like even though I do need
instant instant coffee
no no filter coffee okay in a half year
yeah right I guess the tip depends how
hot it is and how talking like a hundred
and fifty milligrams of coffee maybe and
that would be maybe like an espresso is
70 million yeah this you wanna a
slightly heaped spoon yeah and you know
within half an hour you're like oh God
you're like there's nothing I can do
like there's no along for the ride it's
like you with your unalaq says yes
exactly
very similar yeah not quite the same so
you're just like well like you try your
best to be productive because your side
there geez you sent us a message what
text us both saying guys I've had a
slightly two heaped spoon of coffee this
morning
like can't like can't slow shaking us a
yeah yeah drew it wrecked me I think I
was measuring my heart rate that day in
it yeah with the lovely Withings
watch yeah and yeah just so basically
almost the coffee again not doing that
again I think it's for me doesn't
provide any utility it there's too much
of a and Johnny was like bollocks
like coffee is great I don't feel any of
the downsides of it and then you got you
did a thing
challenged and then you got humble
didn't ya guess so hard so like so I did
30 days of like just tea
so how do I find really funny I don't
know why do you I thought you just wait
a hot drink to me yeah well so the the
deal with my girlfriend was no coffee so
that included no she was saying things
cuz you were like you a lot having us
puer tea yeah I went all along to be
honest like I I did enjoy the morning
coffee the ritual yeah
but as he won the tip sorry then
warranty right yeah I did enjoy the
morning tea and like I bought the I
bought like at Bodum tea press Jesus
Christ because I literally like as soon
as as soon as I agreed to the 30-day
challenge I was straight and I was and I
was like the jumpers come on
I have Youssef has such a low tolerance
to eat your dinner sorry you wipe the
floor with me when we go to the sauna
finding this order year too weird I
guess cuz it's short and intense what I
wanted to come to the sauna so there's a
story behind that okay so for the finish
my teacher I'll um
like I said what yellow Marte puer and
Japanese Sencha all of these things
sound so it's like so I thought he
runner who likes T Tim Ferriss likes t I
look at Tim Ferriss and Jordan did
exactly the same thing so just bought
this stuff just verbatim exactly what he
was doing and just did that
and it's quite like smokey because he
ever mattered even Matta take a very
smoky flavor
yeah but must his very hyphenated though
isn't it only in its not I won't be
saying this to me I thought I overdosed
is well I just take the mick with doses
you see if any like
dose it as its recommended on the back
of the packet it's like 30 milligrams if
you're gonna sell it it's seven quid in
an hour yeah well yeah there is that so
the 720 now so with me and Yusuf have
begun going semi-regularly to sauna and
we're going to begin a swimming a little
swimming regime as well yeah we've got
that Sabina yeah we've got some cool
swim Watts from Sabina
is now like unreal at swimming and has
asked Matt so it was well a bad person
to be a swimmer and is now proper good
so we're following in her aqua immersion
zooming Jasmine pool and your holy
breath yeah even though you get ones and
then you get one then you got to come
back with a different idea so we've been
going sauna video guy Dean and myself
have also gone for a little on a trip so
why are you not coming to the Sun of
this so I used to have a membership at
David Lloyd closer to leisure and while
I was doing I was revising for my ACA
exams I used to use the cafe as a place
to revise and what I used to do was when
exams are approaching I would also like
select my routine my schedule became a
very regimented and like the rest of my
life also dial is like I was like going
in the gym in the morning out look back
up not [ __ ] clear why I was gonna do
in the morning and doing like 20 minutes
of incline walking the sympton audio but
then I go down and do some stretching
and I do you like revision block one I
was glad I was doing like a training
session revision block two and I read at
the time the sauna um like in as you
probably read the same stone like the
fair whack of time in a sauna can have
like real effects on your recovery Ron
Rhonda Patrick yep
PM Ferriss podcast sauna report yeah a
whole host of multi system benefits for
a lot sauna lots and lots so I was like
okay this big dose is three times a week
for 30 minutes yep so I thought three
times a week for 30 minutes sink so it's
good at a minimum I'll do more than that
so I was doing heaped teaspoon I was
basically doing two sessions two
20-minute sessions a day and not not
every day but like every day that my
schedule allowed it was a lot and it got
to the point where I don't know why I
get like 10 minutes is fine 10 to 20
minutes is absolute for me
absolutely yeah there's a curve with
your tolerance isn't there where like
you are
I can i holla warm it's nice tonight
inside my mind
mine is first and second of 15 is fine
third one at ten
I'm out write it so so I I've just I
just stopped other exposure I'm a saint
like you go on holiday or like go
somewhere where there's a sauna and
you're like this should be a nice
experience venture isn't it for yourself
it's like too much mother people are and
then I've done it I've done that - oh
really - yeah and you're like you can't
have anything is there anything else
that you guys have done that to excess
weight where you know you know that
everyone's got a story about like that
one time you were 16 and broke into your
parents like pantry and had loaded
tequila and I can't drink tequila have
you got any of those loans made my own
Rose a wine from mixing white wine and
red wine like then walked into my
parents kitchen and got a stack of like
you know like water quite like shake
your jewellery sat next to my diet and
thought like I'm gonna be these crackers
and just decided to go like when all
that me and my daughter said to me when
I then went upstairs went to bed woke up
while being sick was sick on myself sick
on the floor then thought I'm being sick
stood up stood in the sick slept in a
sick sick again so good so I'm what sick
although me signal all of my bed and I
saw I can't fully remember this pop this
but a party I went downstairs
this isn't like 42:11 is like this and
she's standing in the living room but my
mum start watching TV I walk out on my
feet second so and she was just like you
know like what where do you even begin
with the questions because neither of
them had any idea so this was like some
friends had come round with bottles of
wine yeah I was like Rosie wines just
red wine and white wine mixed together
surely so had a lot of rows a white and
yeah
so that
refuses so when I was 15 I once heard of
one bottle of white and one bottle of
red wine
sube Roseate intently yeah I had did
separately in the mixed inside when he
was it and this was at I was staying at
a friend's house and I did the exact
same thing I'd projectile vomiting if
apparently it looked like someone had
been stood at the bottom of the stairs
with a shotgun and hit someone in the
stomach and it just it was all over the
walls that had cream carpet cream wars
had to pay like 400 pounds to get
everything cleaned and write them a
letter my mom made me write hand write
them a letter my handwriting's always
been terrible so like it took me this
letter took me so the Boreas each left
each word was taking like three minutes
for me to write especially with the
alcohol shakes and stuff yeah and then
honey she'd given me she'd given me a
bunch of towels to go upstairs and like
clean myself off and I'd gone upstairs
left the towels outside picked up one of
the hand towels so I was holding it like
behind me like this but there was a slit
down the back where my ass was hanging
out obviously because I was just holding
this like anything behind me because I
didn't reach all the way around my waist
and I woke up in that conservatory on an
air bed the next day with no
recollection of it happening our house I
hunt horrid what the [ __ ] I think so
sorry
come on but my doesn't involve alcohol
but I might have gone over this in
another podcast but if you are a veteran
of my protein when they first started
you'll know you know when you that way
it was actually my protein you can make
your own like I want three Prasad you
remember CEA the whole point was that
you could make your own custom or a
party oh yeah so they're the cheapest
way the cheapest protein that they had
was Casey in the casein 8 this is
different from micellar casein
so this is like the one in front of the
first like
commercially available protein powders
and it would be a scoop a really thick
set powder you put it in the water or
the milk and you'd shake it and it would
as you shake it it would become more and
more solid until eventually it would be
like boom in your shake Oh to become
this lump of sand a bit like that
Newtonian fluid you know where you mix
cornflour and water
can punch it in it's solid though you
know pour it in it yeah makes a slow
yeah moves called thixotropic
thixotropic thixotropic with an Angus
it's okay substances which you get more
biscuits as you with more and it does
you stir yes there's like that as you'd
shake it be drinking that and I just
having that all the time trying to get
the calories in during Ramadan it's
flavorless it tastes absolutely awful so
it's not just the consistency it's I'm
gonna guess it feels like being punched
in the throat it's gonna feel that
you're making yourself sick or like
being on Geordie Shore
oh it does yeah if it feels like a
finger just slowly putting it stuff down
the back of your throat and it sits in
your stomach heavy everything about it
from top to toe is awful and I remember
like getting down my final liter of it
for the day and should be my I'm so glad
I've done that and I was like no no I
can't handle it through it but running
running to the bathroom got it all over
my maths notes it was the start of the
academic year and so ended up just
having these like casein case and they
tea dried in a kind of wave or the
wobbly way but yeah there will be the
thinking of vom for the rest of the year
is a constant reminder oh yeah there it
is
so moving forward intercept so my win
yes it's mine your win Johnny had been
getting me to get any whiteboard in my
room he was like telling you man listen
yeah one gets some glittery pens and you
yeah right things honey and I think you
do pictures pictures oh why is only one
lifetime
you've broken off my broken Christmas
Jimmy was gonna do a big cinematic thing
while you two were having your own
discussions by making eye contact with a
camera yeah I thought I set my lights
off yeah thinking big dramatic display
we've broken this little ruined it
Michael I'm telling you pressing it
trying to see if there's a
connection Oh Amanda well they're
obviously l-series they're not in
parallel are they that was that's a
these years new physics yes
great so so our lines in this circle
with a crossing yeah so what I've been
using it for - probably not for the
intended purpose
but is using it as like a way to have
serial reminders from summit so Frosty's
across the east conflict yeah honey no
cornflakes but so I drew a big picture
of a tomato tomahto
and that's my reminder to do Pomodoro
walk but the mark though the MIT the
first quote that I wrote on that will
have to be a story one day God one day
me one day you'll be yeah we have the
list of journey has like the pinnacle of
all probably the funniest story the
you've ever heard but it the other the
other problem is the fact that it as as
personally exposing as anything can be
yeah so but if I mean that's a reason to
keep this episode episode 100 could be
for him very well and that would be
around about a year from now lovely
why I'll start psych myself up man I
honestly think you're gonna stocking
with full messages 52 weeks ago to you
said that we would find out what the
embarrassing thing was that happen to
John if they remember I'll record it for
them in a private value
there's hundreds there was a few
requests for a story that I mentioned
there were all I want to hear about how
Yusef did the can't remember my Ivan
come on there's honestly there's so many
requests for stories from you well I
mean in dated as part what in you so the
the quote that I've been that I've been
following for a few months I've rotated
it now but was do not concern yourself
with the opinions of the C players and
this was from Josh Waitzkin chespin Ches
Ches Ches prodigious
black belt in Brazilian Jujitsu peak
performance coach like it's searching
for thingy bobby fischer's yeah
so this is an interview with him and Tim
Ferriss
he was saying that this quote is
essentially in relation to people who
produce things so the athletes and
relative to the C players were who are
the sports critics or the the author and
the literary critics or the artist and
the you know what when pass the ball oh
yeah the armchair expert you're saying
these people are not in your position
for a reason and so if you continually
pander to those low level opinions
Sunday pander then you'll end up
diluting your own art form and so
whatever it is that you're creating be
very careful with who you listen to you
only take on the either expert opinions
or if it's something that's really
overwhelmingly in favor of one thing or
another or your coach so anyone that has
your best interests at heart and to tune
out some of the armchair experts and I
think for me that was something that I
needed to hear it's a cool it's a very
very cool idea and like you know I think
with a lot of any of us who any people
at home who do it job everything's
high-profile I was about to say anyone
who does anything that's high-profile
it's in the public eye but with social
media
everyone's got everyone with [ __ ]
Facebook accounts got an opinion and
like politics and the most nuanced
mm-hmm it's like very very rare that I
ever get messages about the negative
about the podcast with a couple of
people that do I'm like why don't you
mention on your pod commune you don't
[ __ ] have one because you can't speak
sentences that's a hell of a reason
that's very how about vasive isn't it
yeah yeah but yeah like I so we in some
of the stuff we do with helping Petey's
like one of the big barriers to being
online is doing videos speaking to
camera and especially a video that's
live think of something
okay thanks up now we do it that's what
we teach them to do dip hold on three
you know you're going to be absolutely
aroused party feel mint after that oh
wow look at the waveform on Garageband
after that just there is no way I'm
gonna be able to leave that in the audio
version is there it's just gonna sound
like us humping each other like to
announce what we were doing if you're on
the audio version maybe that it don't
make it's create sense of intrigue to go
over to YouTube you need to go after you
to depress the subscribe watch the watch
the for think we do science electrons so
one of the fears is that is being on
video and the thing that I always say to
them is anyone who's criticizing you I
guarantee is not doing videos themselves
people are more afraid of public
speaking than they are of death what the
top three fears are public speaking
spiders and death I think in that all
you're doing here and let me get this
straight
I told you earlier on this evening that
I'm nervous about an event that we're
doing next week and you've reaffirmed
the fact that I should be more terrified
than both spiders and death both of
which I'm pretty scared of yeah it's so
weird justifying my fears but human mind
works like yeah what's your another fail
another win from this year
oh god wins from this year man like
number the business the video has
continued to be successful for me that
feels like bread and butter like it's
more that the status quo of that is that
it continues to grow and continues to do
well doing the podcast this year was new
ground I feel as he watched a podcast
yeah yeah I you know feel very very
thankful and grateful to yourselves and
this is an Nvidia video guy Dean and and
you know all the guests I've had on and
stuff this year so you know and the
listeners at home I really do like we've
topped nearly three and a half million
less in minutes since launching in
February and yeah it's it's super
meaningful I get to sit down with
amazing interesting people the guests
I've got the 2019 ridiculous like the
vice-chairman of algal V advertising
I've got Rory Sutherland who's it
absolute monster in his own right like
I've got T Agra fort a from praxis
before both of them man yeah he's
building a second brain that book is
being made off the back of the course so
I know I get a lot of requests for us to
do a podcast episode about the use of
Evernote so what we might do what might
be cool would be to do a couple like a
little series so we could get us to do
one and Evernote and then cover it cover
the heart of and then within a couple of
weeks
I'll get the Forte episode and I'll get
that on and then he'll just take it to
the extreme nice but yeah man like the
puck has been a big win I said at the
start of the year that I want it to do
it I said at the start of the year as
well oddly this will go against some of
your process goal approaches but I had I
don't like to write I'm big on New
Year's resolutions right I know you guys
have a discussion about this actually in
a second which should be interesting but
I'm bigger New Year's resolutions and I
like the opportunity to reset and
reflect and I think it's important to
period out of your life in that way and
I like the fact that there isn't any
because we could essentially not have an
end of the year it could just be like
thunder re and then he's annoyed you
know I mean like the time just drags on
in our slow march towards death yeah
exactly but you get this you get this
period dies kind of reflection period
and the what was really funny was at the
start of last year I knew I was gonna
have a hard cut physique wise and one of
my goals was to get a fitness cover so I
wanted to get wrote it down don't turn
to do this thing much buzz like right I
won a minion podcast listens we've got
three and a half million less
minutes I'm gonna class that a couple of
other things that I wanted to do and one
of them was gab magazine cover now what
I had in my mind was the fact that I was
going to be the photo on the front of
the magazine but as some of the
listeners may remember in April I wrote
an article that got featured in Muscle &
Fitness and it was on the cover of the
magazine is the biggest Islamic fitness
magazine in the world Islam and fitness
it's amazing
it was Graceland fitness Muslim akin
Fitness yeah and so that was kind of
funny that there's like certain things
have come wrong like that but yeah man
like pocus awesome it's a fantastic
outlet and you know you guys as well in
your own right with it but the propane
want to continue to grow on on every
year and I think it's it's cool that
people have access to this source stuff
for free like it blows my mind on it on
a consistent basis and you know I mean
probably not by the time that this goes
out I suppose for Christmas Eve but
pretty soon after we'll start announcing
some of the things that we've got
planned for next year and like we're
going to be doing some live podcasts and
the locations and the shows that we're
doing the matter that I'm Scott and I am
of spiders and I'm terrified my
sphincter is tensioning already at the
thought of it wrapped up nice and tight
so moving forward into next year first
off are you going to do New Year's
resolutions have you got an approach to
them do you tend to reflect at the end
of the year
how do you play journal uh so no I
probably won't set New Year's
resolutions I think I try as much as
possible to just not see it I mean even
when I was more goal centric I tried to
not see as January the first new me just
because like January the 12th is gonna
be no different to today if in terms of
ever from a practical sense so I think
waiting to start stuff gives a lot of
people a reason to write off between now
and then hmm which like it is not
criticism like I've done that way so
obviously it with our clients every yeah
every single year
easily done firm and and I've I've had
the thought pattern of like yeah but I
will be get to start on Monday or the
big one which is yeah we get to start
the first of January but you're still
gonna have the same fears and concerns
and doubts about it now as you will on
the first of January nurse who you were
on the first of February like so you are
right it's an arbitrary day it is but it
is a nice it's a it's a marking like a
stake in the ground to say you know
that's a year gone by am i heading in
the right direction something this is a
very morbid way to take things but
something else that fight is that
surprise to anyone that's listening that
way it's actually going to say something
they thought was him yeah so something
else from the Darren brown book is he
talks about death and something that I
have I don't really know why but over
the past year and a bit I ain't just as
you get into your late 20s you're like
you become aware of like you know feel
this like I'm 21 and bulletproof and I'm
on you chronically aware of your own
mortality yeah approach 30 so that for
me has been quite a theme this year I
suppose of like wow you know you're
heading into your 30s you're heading
into their life and actually you know
you could easily you know you diagnose
or something or like your life and even
even if your life is being lived to its
fullest extent you've had 30 of the
years so far and so that right Darren
has a lot of thoughts about death in the
book but I think one of them is just
being constantly you know the momentum
or IV might be mindful of death and I
think having a yearly review or even
having a monthly review or a weekly
review prevents this like
oh [ __ ] Fifty's drudging through yeah
and having having a point at which like
am I going in the right direction or not
and if I'm not then what am I gonna do
about it is very important and so I
think having a a retrospective view and
what am I going to change great but
personally in terms of second year's
resolutions probably not I've already
the most harrowing experience of a guy
who was 45 I think where his late 40s
and he just recognized that he'd pissed
away his life and he was like and he was
someone he was like I know that I had
the capacity I was intelligent but I
just just didn't just kind of like
procrastinated and it didn't really do
anything for that time he's like I'm
looking back and I'm so heartbroken
there's a totally reversible as my
family about it and reading that it was
like wow that's really yeah you know but
for me for New Year's resolution I'm too
impatient on too eager to get stuck into
new projects to get started with things
I feel a lot of the time when looking
back over the mistakes I've made over
the year or anything it's like a gray
hum pulling at the stocks like there's
too much of urgency you want to fix that
now yeah then waiting for for it and you
start so the 90-day goal process keeps
me interested enough to at least be
close together and then at least you can
still change process goals and there's
at least there's kind of four quadrants
where which we work in which is what
we've done recently obviously I'm not
against the idea of doing new year
resolution I think probably the thing
that I would do if I were to start this
year is fewer things and all right you
know that we that we change the slogan
of our business from simple rules
dramatic results to do fewer things
better for that reason because it's so
easy to try and start 24 habits in one
go James clay talks about if you try and
start 12 habits and one go you end up
doing none of them at the end of the
year whereas if you just say I'm gonna
do one habit nail it for each month and
then move on to the next one then you'll
get 12 habits from the
that's a that's a very successful way to
go about it couple things to touch on
there the thing that you said about the
the guy that realized he'd wasted his
life anyone who wants to go down a
YouTube binge if you search for I am the
man Jordan Peterson warned you about and
it's this guy who looks like a
psychopath a thumbnail very very
cleverly designed thumbnail and it's a
guy British guy and basically what he
says is that this story that you've just
said there he's got a wife and a couple
of kids and he's 4550 years old and he
says but I realized that I've wasted my
life and he's talking very deadpan
direct into the camera and it's
harrowing it's so harrowing to watch it
was accessible YouTube channel now
though presumably very secure I mean
that one did that one maybe one half a
million views I think
have you seen American Beauty no watch
America gets Helmut Kohl because it's
it's basically a guy he like has that
and then ends up finding like this
scenes in the film on either talking
about the beauty of like a plastic bag
foot floating in the wind but it's like
this guy's just like live this like
dreary existence and then quit his job
buys a car it's a fantastic film my
father has enough to watch though so
yeah I think you
you both are maybe a slightly and
representative sample for people who do
habits yeah because both of us are
saying like for God's sakes stop doing
so and it's an arbitration light it's an
arbitrary yeah so but I think that for
me is someone who does one of the
reasons that I like January first is
again as you say it is an arbitrary date
but there's something about the force
reflection and begin period it feels
like starting anew if I was to give some
advice to people who were considering
you know you will be watching us
hopefully before January the first book
even if you're not it doesn't matter but
I would spend the time you have up until
January first thinking about what you
want to achieve when you get there and
beginning to get the things prepared
because a lot of the time people get to
January 1st and that right I'm gonna
start the gym no [ __ ] I've got no shoes
I'm hungover
yeah you like no hang on mate like what
is it that you want to do you want to
hit the ground running you've got no
[ __ ] gym shoes like yeah it's true
okay right next Monday yeah yeah exactly
and then you start your new year's
resolution on January 7th or something
you might as well so in December so yeah
but you know the meaning for this big
like iconic day you ever just look at
Jim's last ban to come like yeah like
some one week we had a big brass band
come to fit like our school graduation
thing and they played Lord of the Rings
don't know if you remember that big
yeah and you know that like it was this
massive bill another guy with a big drum
and all they're like you know the slow
kind of from the sea of of Windows like
yeah and then builds up that one guy
doing the solo and he got it wrong and
everyone just cracked up on him so I was
pleased I was in that band then what I
thought wasn't didn't server thank God
you were in that band I were playing the
saxophone so did you watch this occur
yeah I wasn't here oh no no no you play
the saxophone great five stop the
[ __ ] press what happened
you've taken your pants off and you play
the saxophone I played I have great five
saxophones Johann agnes blob nursing
prepare please the saxophone
yep in that band where he was in the
crowd are ya mate mum - um absolutely
there's also a I was in a singing group
for when I was if we being transported
oh yeah Christmas universe you know when
we were put into the YouTube holding
baby we've been sent out into the wrong
Johnny isn't it that's why the light
didn't work and yeah I thought we were
here to do at Christmas podcast and it
turns out we're in some [ __ ]
alternate universe where only one light
only Christmas jumper works so I was in
a one of my teachers had a his singing
career he was
a guitarist and he used the apart
portion of the choir that I was also in
to be his backing singing group
so I'm gonna CD singing that's great
somewhere
it's a follow from bed no no wow so much
about girls New Year's New Year's
stumbling at first hurdle Brian brass
band does it make sure you have running
shoes basically yeah
just prepare prepared before you just
we've literally gone through all the
points we're just going back through
them again so yeah you're right like I
think if you're gonna do a new year's
resolution and you're gonna treat this
January first as this holy day as an
arbitrary thing for heaven's sake and
they do it properly don't repair yeah
because if you're not then all you've
done is delay delay fail yeah yeah
fantastic and we always think we're
gonna feel different waking up on
January 1st most likely you're gonna
feel terrible waking up on January 1st
but I feel I'm gonna have you remembered
yes just what is it you know it's like
you know you'd be wanting to sneeze for
ages a new Genesis the best thing
something coming out of you so we coming
out fantastic so it was - I'm joking it
was to set so for setting a goal a
different way of setting a goal on the
1st of January is to set a so it was
what was prompted what prompted this was
you said used between now and January -
I think and one of the problems that I
think people have with that is like well
I don't really know what I want to do
where do I begin with goal setting but
then everyone said well you ever think
what you really want and like [ __ ]
office didn't exactly so like sit down
and write it as ambitiously as you'd
like at a perfect day from start to
finish and then that becomes the
skeleton for all of the goals this was
something that I did when I was in my
second year of uni and pretty much got
it I mean that's that's what I've
managed to get to Delos towards on a
morning now everything I do before
midday if you gave me the option like
yeah like if I don't limited money and
maybe fly somewhere or something but
within reality within the realms of
reality mm-hmm you asked me what would
you like to do on a morning up until
from 6:00 a.m. until midday mm-hmm it
would be exactly what I do so that's
that man is more important than anything
anything else because that's literally
how you spend your life which is all
that there is anyway so I think what
would what might be quite nice of you
touched upon a cold deeds light is there
any quotes from monsieur that that come
to mind
johnny or not put you on the spot there
there's any of the things I love that
one about the C players I think it's
just it's a much greener way of saying
like lions don't concern themselves with
opinions of the Sheep
yes so why do you it just immediately
makes me think fear 500 jelly bean
freshness this is so good at like just
like societies like the specific things
like think you know so you know how did
you know else this particular person's
got catch flights not feelings and their
bio on instant yep feelings yeah that's
what I was thinking about interesting
where Jimmy Choos just the survey
there's a whole whole race of people
it's a generation of girls have you got
a quote if not I can I can fill in while
you probably not and I'm not sure I will
you know your again you don't put
individual things on a pedestal you
would have had a concept from a book
that you've enjoyed the most
I put people on a pedestal okay
Derren Brown was already a big a big win
for you so I loved magic as a kid yeah
and like reading more about him and
magic as made me realize why I like
magic because it's it's a source of its
way trying to impress people when you
feel like you aren't impressive and then
that's what leads items are impressive
thanks man but that's what leads it no
searching till like physically prove
yourself and a whole host of things but
yeah so him Tim Ferriss is someone but I
followed for ages Anton Anton Anton
creel at Anton k:r is it hero II watches
you die L think so
the real career time to get career in
the six minutes hurry today I read a
quote there like so every day there's a
quote in there
there's a quote from David Allen which
like I read it like this so it's it must
to be olives like most of the quotes
like that which is more around the stuff
that you serve and I are spending more
time discussing at the moment which is
like your ability to sit and deeply
aggressively focus on one thing until
it's completed and what's the one thing
that's helped you to to do that that
we've both well I'll get you guys okay
so it's a David's quote was your ability
to produce output or something like that
is directly or your your power to
produce output is directly respond
directly associated with your ability to
like relax or something like that in
other words you should be putting as
much effort and intensity into your
relaxation and rest as you are with your
work I'm very guilty of just like all
the other work that just kind of fills
this other than the challenge in the
six-week diary this week is to schedule
and plan protect free time and do things
in it that aren't work-related so the up
cold turkey for Mac is a new killer
warhead just be careful before you
download it just be just breathe and
just respect it like it does exactly
what it says you briefly explain what
cold turkey does the Mac so it will
block access to apps or websites on
either for a period of time or on a
schedule there's an upgrade isn't this
so that's like the that's the Pluto
version but there's a depleted uranium
version so it was when I first got it
wasn't steep over yeah yeah I notice in
one of the settings in advance
there's a little toggle switch that says
frozen turkey on or off I was like oh
what's that
that looks nice pop it over the
explanation it was like frozen turkey
will lock you out of your laptop at
times you and I remember I got off that
like get on another menu recently read
deep work on users recommendation and
thought like so in that in that book
they talked about this idea of fixed
schedule productivity so having a
deadline at the end of every day
or the end of any task you're trying to
do so they had to be gym session or
whatever that you cannot and do not
shoot over so I was like well I'm [ __ ]
at that because I'm like I'll finish
work at 5 o'clock and I never do so is
that right well I'm just gonna lock
myself out my laptop fixed time every
day put frozen turkey on I remember
thinking like this is just like the
stand a bit of software wouldn't do
anything 5:30 your screen just goes
great and in replace in where was your
apt and everything is just a quote that
says like you run your day your day runs
you or something like some [ __ ] like
that you know oh my god I and you're
like ok laptop off back on again tongue
on my laptop you know write myself up
man
but it's fantastic you've got it as well
yeah so I used it for I'm still deciding
if I get I know long so I'm still hot
position unhearable Egyptian so realize
that a lot of the time sync that I was
doing was from switching time from
having a Destruction come up or checking
messages or whatever and thinking heart
in you to second job to reply to this or
whatever and it ends up completely
derail in your chain of train of
thoughts and everything else and
responding to messages causes more to
come back up so I've set iMessage and a
lot of communications apps into cold
turkey and set it so that every 30
minutes I get a five minute window to
blast response people which Johnny so
certainly felt and and then foot it it's
excellent
because it's the it's the good hybrid
ideally I'd like to go back to having a
total offline period until midday
unfortunately to do yeah this is a
certain and I know that everyone's got
an excuse or I can't do it kiss me but
I'm trying to try and do it medical
degree and run a business here so
there's a couple of things yeah a
[ __ ] break Nate yeah it's a reed deep
work deep works I Cal Newport quote read
deep work and DN atomic habits and those
if you master those two things still
need to know someone needs if someone
get a late Christmas present that wants
to start reading some stuff for the New
Year get those two books for people
atomic habits by James Elliot and deep
work by Cal Newport and happiness or
happy pond by divider umbrella put those
three books Intel out you honestly you
people were recognized I've got happy in
my light in the library ready to
everybody to start on my wish list on it
took being almost bigger book ten hours
yeah [ __ ] quote he's my my camera
doesn't his room is from a guy called
Daniel Ingram who we interviewed this
year a any physician did 14 years of
meditation seven of which were intensive
and he completed meditation so he fully
decentralized his awareness from here to
everywhere and he talks about his
subjective experience in a very grounded
and very kind of physiological in
neurophysiological way which really
resonates with me because it's like he's
not just a quack that's gone off the
deep end like he's very systematic and
basically one of his quotes was
wishy-washy practice leads to
wishy-washy results that's my current
quote on my board because he says
obviously if you sit down and you just
kind of half meditating you're not
really doing a specific method or
anything you're not gonna get anywhere
and he says Vipassana meditation which
is the the guess like what mindfulness
has been distilled into is almost
treated like a competitive sport if
you're practicing seriously where you
look at how many internal sensations can
you recognize and spot
for a second and he says when you build
up to ten consistently it's a ten per
second then you know that you're on the
right track which to me is still a way
off and think to consistently for 30
minutes spot ten sensations a second but
because if you treat something with that
level of precision and that level of
focus then you will you're guaranteed to
make results it's a lovely way to look
at it man mmm pretty good that's great
so you read turning pro by Steven
Pressfield no there's a similar kind of
okay message lucky things properly yeah
that's a really good way to look at
things for everything right like you're
only gonna get no matter whether not how
many times you go through an experience
the number time of that experience is
still the first time you've done it if
you've been to the gym 200 times that's
still the first two hundred and first
time that you've got yeah and it means
that like you're never gonna get that
chance again so for heaven's sake
actually my talk with Jim it's the
biggest that we see so many people that
are on the inflection point of
increasing marginal returns so
translation like that they're at the
point where they're they're going to the
gym they're having a protein shake that
they're doing ninety percent of the
effort with 90 percent of the the pain
and the the bollocks that is involved
with that and time and everything else
but because they're just like not really
doing compound movements or they're only
sticking to machines or that they're not
gonna trust in their calories or yeah
they're not pushing the volume it's not
like a nail in with a foam hammer yeah
it's like the same effort you take all
the effort longer but that amazing
operated such an amazing analogy is
definitely one of the learnings for me
from this year has been that your mind
is going to give up an awfully long or
awfully sooner than your body when it
comes to training and that people are
very concerned about overtraining
and although well that's been a very raw
lesson for you this year yeah man well I
just
I I'm very surprised that my body's
capacity I'm by no means even moderately
capable endurance work or training
regularly like 22 days five days a week
for me
destroys me but I'm still able to
function but I get literally I get
double the progress that I would have
done a.m. it is a factor of two and if
you concerned about the progress that
you're making with a work project or in
the gym or with your relationship or
whatever it is work done equals time
times intensity that's like it's like
the [ __ ] conservation of energy like
thermodynamics equation work done equals
time times intensity so if you can up
both of those you're laughing like if
you can train twice a day and if you can
train twice as hard that's four sessions
that you again yeah I mean the number of
people who were anywhere near
overtraining people are so worried about
overtraining on they today yeah train
legs on Sunday I play football on
Tuesday so I don't strain legs could
listen my pantry honestly yeah my
Achilles it's like if the tendon it's i
defibrillated remember the guy who
coached me he was giving me lots of
volume yes so the first week from that I
remember coming home from a training
session and just being immediately
although a bed-bound like flu type
symptoms and I was icy honest and
honestly so that I had done more volume
in that week than I had previously in a
month I'm on my pre-flight around the
volume like yeah man intensity very high
it was a percentages that were designed
to bring you to the brink of disre
it's not only a bit worse the
percentages at horrendous but also like
that level of volume through any human
body regardless of what your Marcus's
are mm-hmm
because I mean your your deadlift marks
is 3:23 15 12 3 12.5 oh okay so like the
even 7080 percent of that like it's a
heavy weight yeah tip
there's a lot through as long a topic oh
I'm just loading the buzz and I'm
arguing us over and over again that's
the closest another point weirdly I
remember the next day waking up and
feeling ok I just I was following a
program like when even a program you
follow it kept going and lo and behold
your dad so like I remember thinking at
the time
I have quadrupled my volume here and
Here I am adapting to it so there we go
man and you know you can apply that or
anything kind your mark your mind will
fail long before your body ever does
injure by Alex Hutchinson oh my god if
someone wants a more sporty side book
amazing absolutely fantastic and if you
want to find your physical limit go do
it with amine which is 2020 Rover squad
do it safely of course but safety 20
depends you did it for like six months
or some missed six weeks yeah Brit Milah
I remember throwing up
Rosberg way down my top quite frequently
like whenever I would train one on
stantly doing something that makes it
wrong this is a good good for a life
fail actually so it was a program called
squats in milk which is where you have
four point seven meters of whole milk a
day so I gather that American gallon of
whole milk and you do widow-makers
0.7 liters yeah so two of the big very
extreme weight gain strategy it was
horrible it ruins your bowels you
absolutely just complete columns of
liquid all day but yeah so and then the
training program is three times a week
Widowmaker squats so you take your 10
rep max put it on your back and you're
not allowed to rack it until you do 20
reps
so you just the set maybe takes three
four minutes so you like of hell in
common oh yeah it's really nasty and
different things happen to people on rep
11 so I taste blood you audio broadcast
loses hearing that or without you I lose
my hearing energy hearing some labs in
Karen but different symptoms well yeah
he passes out only after yeah I am a
digital take such a big all right it's
the thing is however a happening and
thinking this can't be rack 11 there's
nothing magical about rep 11 every
single time at rep 11 but there's no
blood but that metal that kind of metal
taste yeah that's what they call him
CrossFit they called Frank off-brand
cough you know when you do from you get
the front cuff off you get that
face-to-face with the devil yeah so any
any parting thoughts
obviously it's Christmas Eve for us
right now
technically kind of merry crowd in the
future a morbid in a few in there were
in the future past of podcast land it's
Christmas Eve it is merry Christmas
everyone Merry Christmas thank you
[Music]